ah merci alors ils nous ont rejoints
voilà koh lanta la colère des candidats
trahi par la production on à dany
mercinat et on à la jimmy jimmy
savamment jimmy lemi qui étaient déjà
venus l'un et daniela il a participé à
la saison avec gerald ben voilà on
rappelle alors vous n'avez pas été
rappelé on va on va rappeler
donc tout ce qui s'est passé le 22 mars
2013 tf1 annonce la mort d'un candidat
gérald babin d'un arrêt cardiaque
survenu lors de la première journée de
tournage
les candidats sont rapatriés en france
et la saison est annulé deux semaines
après on apprend le dessin du médecin le
décès du médecin thierry costa qui
n'aurait pas supporté la mort de girac
banques concernant les candidats qui ont
participé au seul jour de tournage
pendant la mort de girac babin ils ont
la promesse de participer à une
prochaine saison de koh lanta
sauf que tout ne va pas se passer comme
prévu et deux candidats voilà qui sont
là vous allez nous vous allez nous
raconter à l'époque ça avait fait
beaucoup parler
regardez candidats de 25 ans était mort
d'un arrêt cardiaque sur le tournage sur
le premier jour de tournage de koh lanta
giral babin 25 ans participant à la 16e
saison de koh lanta a succombé à une
crise cardiaque
vous parlez de gérald moi je parle aussi
du du médecin thierry costa qui s'est
donné la mort après voilà et ouais il
s'est suicidé
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
ancré en moi qui est entre créant nous
voilà donc c'était les propos de denis
brogniart et voilà donc il y aura des
candidats exceptionnellement repris
voilà après sept saisons caubère puisque
ça va retourner vous quel est votre
problème
pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes énervé
aujourd'hui vous mais qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire on m'a dit que vous étiez né avec
vous entier le trail par la production
dany pourquoi n'en ont pas vraiment
énervé mais plutôt déçu parce que en
fait on est on a un peu premier
oralement qu'on avait
quand l'accord passé l'année suivante et
on a fait les castings au hasard fait
mais après pendant il vient mail delà de
tf1 qui a qui nous ont vraiment un banni
de collatéral zotique ne voterai plus
jamais que c'est définitif ça sert à
rien il fallait passer à autre chose
alors vous vous étiez sur la dernière
saison qui est annulé mais mine de rien
on mai dernier on apprenait que la dix
neuvième saison de koh lanta aux îles
fidji été annulé en raison d'une
agression sexuelle présumée un candidat
aurait tenté d'agresser sexuellement une
autre candidate et sans suite des
procédures dont confrontant les deux
concernés on se fait un petit récap
aussi et vous n'êtes pas repris alors
non on n'est pas déçu j'avais par
postuler à 9 ans voulait plus faire de
la prochaine saison de koh lanta
interrompu le tournage de la prochaine
édition de koh lanta a été annulée une
concurrente qui a fait état de faits
susceptibles de relever d'une agression
sexuelle une participante de ce jeudi
que cette nuit là elle aurait été
victime de faits qui pourraient être
qualifiés d'agression sexuelle
il s'agit de candide renard 21 ans la
fille de l'entraîneur de football hervé
renard le candidat qu'elle accuse lui
dément formellement ces accusations j'ai
cru comprendre que dans ce dossier il y
avait des enregistrements nocturne de
surveillance de vidéosurveillance il
faudrait examiner ce que ces vidéos
révèle voilà alors gilles vers des cas
une immense hypocrisie de la production
parce que rien n'est clair même si
alexia laroche-joubert aujourd'hui à vos
équipes nous a dit qu'elle ne comptait
jamais reprendre d'anciens candidats
c'est fou elle les maintient en éveil
elle leur fait faire des castings elle
les tests ils promettent vous allez être
pris quoi qu'on en pense je suis pas
forcément favorable mais on laisse ces
gens dans l'ignorance alors dit oui oui
vous pour ne pas qu'il parle vous allez
être prié attendent et c'est parfois
parfois même on fait croire à certains
qui vont être pris pour pas qu'ils
balancent c'est là où ça va pas ça c'est
hypocrite c'est pas bien franchement
vous êtes d'accord exquis ouais je pense
que par exemple moi pour ma saison
sylvain du sol est revenue c'est parce
que il y avait comme sur le moment j'ai
voulu venir protéger enfin aider un
petit peu et 10 face aux accusations
bien sûr mais sans les personnes
présents aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils
ont tout espoir d'être pressée ça
intéressant
oui et donc pas ce qu'ils sont ils
étaient plusieurs à vouloir venir après
que monsieur castaldi a dévoilé le cv de
deux des dix oui exactement dit robin
que tout le monde du conte a été
plusieurs à vouloir venir un petit peu
et c'est de défendre sans trop d'efforts
parce qu'on sait pas dire ce qu avait
dedans mais bon voilà on trouvait ça un
petit peu moche qu'ils se fassent accusé
qu'en plus on le plante au niveau de
l'opinion publique
donc on était plusieurs à vouloir venir
au final voilà alors il ya une candidate
qui va être reprise
voilà dans cette saison benjamin mais
moi je comprends le point de vue la
production il y en a une c'est assez
injuste mais on a oui on fait pas un
nouveau match avec débats l'ancien c'est
un peu un peu vieillissant ils ont
repris et bien d'autres oui quoi on m'a
confirmé que c'était un tout nouveau
casting vraiment confirmé à une personne
qui a été repris dans je crois c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit et gilles verdez c'est ça
là aussi une immense ambiguïté et là je
vais balancer quelque chose qui va pas
plaire du tout à la production la
candidate qui est ou qui a failli être
repris parce qu'on a un immense doute
c'est charlotte d'accord qui était dans
votre saison voilà vous rigolez mais
laissez moi finir avant de répondre
charlotte mais qu'il a dit n'est pas
énervé arrive calme toi et tu as fait
koh lanta il a sorti une machette
charlotte sellami la confidente celle
qui était la plus proche lors de la
dernière saison de candide d'accord
d'ailleurs alors finalement on m'a dit
qu'elle était plus reprises c'est pour
ça les reprises au départ c'est pour ça
qu'il ya le bug mois l'info que j'ai
mais il sait qu'on lui a fait croire
qu'elle allait être pris pendant très
longtemps même elle elle l'a cru
d'accord ne pas qu'elle parle sur la
série des renvois là et ça peut passer
croyez-moi je saurai à la fin ce qui si
ça s'est passé c'est dégueulasse
moi je suis totalement contre qui
reprennent une seule personne tu
reprends personne ou du roulement tout
le monde après vient de me dire qu'il ya
eu sept jours de tournage c'est rien
c'est le jour où il paye les dégâts
collatéraux de ce qui s'est passé entre
deux personnes il ya danger t'enlève les
deux personnes tu reprends les mêmes
temps reprend deux nouveaux pas pourquoi
tu reprends la salle une dame qui sont
sept jours ya pas eu d'élimination n'y a
rien
non mais non mais ils veulent pas parce
que et ils ont déjà connu lima que j'ai
parlé aux journalistes qui travaillent
dessus là d'accord qui m'a dit qu' aucun
des anciens le dessus même pas un comme
si on les bat on a fait l'europe ils ont
failli robbins mais cela ne s'est pas
fait puisqu'elle le voit donc lé dessus
une fille qui sépare les merdes c'est
une fille faut pas dire demain quelle
personne m'a dit il ya si j'ai dit c'est
charlotte toile hawaï aimerions qu'une
personne dessus qui n'a été repris pour
le moment et se hisse en revanche qu'ils
disent c'est que pour la prochaine s'ils
veulent faire une saison voilà ce qui le
rendit totalement neutre qui parles-tu
se passe très très bien pour le moment
neutre sans histoire est que cette
saison se passe très très bien pour la
saison d'après il ferait revenir des
anciens candidats
voilà ce qu'ils leur disent elles fine
oui effectivement moi j'ai contacté
alexia laroche-joubert stamm et ses
productions en parlent à tort les infos
renchérit henri c'est un amour alexia
maison j'aime beaucoup et vanilla nous
sommes toujours plaints d'amphoux aucun
aucun candidat de l'année fin de l'année
précédente et que vous étiez tous au
courant que vous avez tous été mis au
courant donc ya pas de zones d'ombré la
cierva chez moi mais ça n'a rien à voir
parce qu'elle ne dit pas tout là la
raison mais elle ne dit pas tout elle ne
donne pas les vraies raisons
attention elle dit papa tout est ce
qu'on vous a fait quoi vous allez
refaire une saison
non mais parce qu'on est reparti au
casting de l'année suivante axa il est
donné l'enchaînement donc vous refaites
complètement casting donc on fait non à
se tourner vers la fin on a des deux par
dernière partie du casting et mais moi
pour un casting je sentais déjà qui
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
vous sentez vraiment d'avant soit la
maxime en tout cas si alex l ai dit à
tout le monde tout cas mercredi qui sont
déjà deux là où c'est pas très claire
charlotte c'est pas trés car si l y
aider tout le monde est candidat devait
être débile parce qu'ils n'ont pas
compris mais ils sont pas des bides
alors mise en scène dans la tête des
producteurs j'imagine que aussi à côté
chats noirs et j'imaginais iso
malheureusement ils sont pour rien mais
je pense qu'on a été dans participants
d'une épreuve où il ya eu un tel drame
on considère que là ça y est à une sorte
de photo
et après je vois voilà on va être ré
après je vois le bail voilà et joyon
propre vouloir vous vous êtes déçu de
pas être avoir été repris oui évidemment
non mais nous ça fait cinq ans déjà donc
avec quand même donc classées noires ou
considérer que koh-lanta c'est fini j'ai
comme un petit espoir est un genre qui
nous rappelle pour faire une pour après
une saison avec les nouveaux et les
anciens jaillir la presse fois encore
même si nautique c'est défier fort
boyard et voulu vous venez vous je vous
sens alors pour moi s'il me trouve je
joue je parlais clés voilà dit pas si
les téléspectateurs au sens que la même
chose que moi je me sens d'écouté par
koh lanta n'ont pas dégoûté mais fouet a
laissé un petit peu c'est vrai je le
sente une idée koh lanta sans rigoler
c'est comme si moi tu le dis tf1 le
voilà il ya des trucs que j'aime bien
sûr tf1 ya des trucs que j'aime moins
bien mais koh lanta j'ai l'impression
pour moi j'adore koh lanta parionsweb
contador si je dois expliquer un petit
peu le début moi ils m'ont appelé et
j'ai pas postuler donc ils sont venus me
chercher donc ces quelques mois vous
vous êtes venus ou des titres aussi chez
ou non qu elle le met les produits
l'entraînement j'ai connu cela à faire
[Musique]
comment ils vous ont trouvé j'avais déjà
été repérée bien autres car si le
dossier a été passé à cette prod et a
donc ils m'ont appelé donc moi c'est pas
quelque chose qu'il au départ voulait
avec quelques démissions moral je me tue
soit je voulais faire quoi vous dirai
pas dire oui à ce que les marseillais
s'étaient pas ça les marseillais
seraient pas la coiffure a pas de
tatouage par deux revues de survie c'est
wild the wild faire beaucoup mieux que
l'otage donc les doigts tu voulais faire
du web et wap et pour koh lanta voilà
c'est énorme et un mec tu veux faire les
amis pour les amours en fait je vais
partir avec michael voulait des réponses
à des questions avec la balle a fait
deux mecs ils se retrouvent à manger des
années c'est donc pour rien à voir les
fairways var est retrouvé dans koh lanta
voir on est quand même sur deux bien sûr
oui c'est donc le nom qu'on m'a appelé
me demandant si ça m'intéressait donc
que j'ai dit que ça m'intéressait donc
on m'a mis un petit peu se mettre dans
les mains et après me le retirer moi ça
m'a un peu dégoûté mais ça s'arrête là
que la production bas il a donc lui
tassé fini avec le saint et nantes 18
non et oui et ce à quoi dans la vie j'ai
préparé envoyé pour un tour du monde
d'accord comment donc bah vous allez
partir mais son koh lanta quoi un moment
c'est juste les aventuriers mouvoir à
bateaux passer et vous fait quoi de rémy
je fais sportif coach sportif
d'accord on va très bien bon bah
j'espère vous allez refaire koh lanta en
tout cas voilà je vous le dis il n'y
aura personne de repris dans koh lanta
mais il ya eu ce petit truc voilà avec
cette jeune fille qui a failli être
reprises donc koh lanta va bien
reprendre ce sera en janvier à l'antenne
sur tf1 c'est sarah moi je peux t'on du
printemps je pense que vous c'est vous
qui avez raison il se retourna chanson
web avoir vos mots maximum